عقاب التشهير لفضح مرتكبي الجرائم سلاح
اشهرته سلطات بالسودان كتحذير شديد
لعصابات السلب والنهب والسرقه بالاكراه
شرطه ولايات الجزيره هددت في منشور بعرض
مقبوض عليه لايف وبالتالي كشف المتهم لكل
الناس الشرطه ردت على المعترضين على
التشهير بالمجرمين وقالت ان السرقه
والترويع المواطنين تحت تحديد السلاح اكبر
مهدد وفيه انتهاك للحقوق ايضا
ومباشره نفذت وعيدها ببث مقاطع مصوره لما
وصفته باخطر معتدي سرقات النشل وعلى الرغم
من ارتفاع ظاهره انتشار جرائم السرقه
بواسطه الدراجات الناريه الا ان الموضوع
اثار جدلا ويؤكد الرافضون له انه يخالف
القاعده القانونيه التي تنص على ان المتهم
بريء حتى تثبت ادانته
[موسيقى]
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا كل من المحامي عبد
الشكور حسن والكاتب الصحفي علي ابو عرقي
صباح الخير لكما صباح
الخير يعني استاذ
عبد الشكور يعني انت مع التشهير بالمجرم
وهذا قد يكون من الناحيه القضائيه كونك مع
هذا الاجراء الا انا
يعني الا تخشى ان يصبح المجرم مجرما
محترفا بدل ان يتوب بعد التشهير به علنا
الحقيقه طبعا انواع المجرمين اربع مجرمين
في مجرم محترف اصلا طبيعه انه يعيشوا
وياكل على الجريمه وفي مجرمه عرضي وفي
مجرم زهاني وفي مجرم عصابي فالمجرم العرضي
فهذا ليس مشكله لانه المال السايب بيعلموا
اما المشكله عمال الزهاري والحصابي فهذا
يعني مجرم تعاطى مخدر او مريض نفسيا او
مريض عقليا لكن المجرم العرضي لا بد من
صوره ولا بد من نشر يعني كل الاسماء الاسم
بالكامل والصوره كامله ليه لانه هذا
المجرم ما لم ينشر وما لم يكن معروف سيشكل
جريمه في حته ثانيه لذلك حمايه المجتمع
وبالحق المجتمع ان يرسل صوره هذا المجرم
والقانون اباحى واتاح واعطى الحق للنيابه
بالنشر على المجرم الذي اخفى نفسه بالنشر
على المجرم الذي يعني سيغادر البلاد كما
اعطى الشرطه
بحق انها تحتفظ بكل سجلات المجرمين تصويرا
وبصمه لذلك لا بد من ان تكون ذلك
المجرمين يتم التشهير بهم
لا في حاجه بسموها التنطيط الجنائي
التنميط الجنائي بتحدد نوع الجريمه ان
كانت الجريمه عنيفه جريمه سياسيه جريمه
اقتصاديه جريمه نفسيه فعلى حسب الجريمه
لكن الجرائم الكبرى والجرائم والعنيفه
التي تقع على الاطفال كالاغتصاب وتقع على
المراه كالاغتصاب وتقع على جسم الانسان
كالقتل او الاصابات الجسيمه
والعصابات الان التنظيم الاجرامي الموجود
تبقى عصابات منظمه شوف لابد من نشرها هذه
واحده الحاجه الثانيه لابد من نشر جرائم
المسؤولين الذين يحتالون عن اعمال العام
والذين يغشون في السلع وكل هذه الاشياء
لابد من نجرى صورهم وذلك تاديبا لهم استاذ
عبد الشكور يعني خلينا نسال من هو ضد
الصحفي علي بوعكري استاذ علي يعني قد يكون
الفضح
بهذه الجريمه يؤثر
نعم
قد يكون الفضح وسيله ردع للمجرم خصوصا في
مجتمع العرب في مجتمعنا العربيه
بالفعل انا اتفق انا انا اتفق معك على
اساس انه
الشرطه هي ليس محاط بها ان تقوم بالاحكام
بل الجهه العدليه هي التي تقوم بتنفيذ
الحكم وبفعل وهذه الممارسات تساعد في
سلبيه وفي زعزعه المجتمع السوداني
بشكل
غير صحيح ونحن نعيش الان في ظروف هشه
تستدعي ان نتعامل معها بتوخي ونتعامل معها
بالحذر بالنسبه للحاله العامه التي تمر
بها البلاد وفي كل الاحوال هذا فعل مستنكر
كان يفترض
الى عندنا كمان بالمجتمعات العربيه انه
لما يتم التشهير بهؤلاء المجرمين اللي
حيضرر ايضا اهاليتهم اما اختها اخوه يعني
كلهم يحكم عليهم بجريمه هذا الشخص
على اساس المجرم ارتكب جدا ليس له حصانه
طال المجرم ارتكب جريمه ليست له حصانها في
عقوبه صحيحه عقوبه ممتده كعقوبه السجن
بتكون ممتده طالما دخل السجن معناه يعني
العقوبه وصلت
الاسره لكن
الفرصه الاستاذ علي حق الرد استاذ علي
شيء مثل هذا
شيء مثل هذا شيء مثل هذا من المفترض ان
يقوم به
ان تقوم
فرصه
جهازا تنفيذي لاصدار الاحكام
نعم بل يجب عليها ان يقوموا هذا وفق قرار
قانوني يخص المحكمه سواء كان مرتبط
بمرتبط باي خطوه يفترض ان يكون عبر
المحكمه او عبر النيابه سيد علي سؤال
سريعا يعني انت كصحفي كيف تعاملت مع هذا
الخبر
هذا التعامل هذا التعامل من المفترض ان
يتبني عليه اسس هذه الاسس يجب ان لا تمص
الشرف اشاره السمعه اشاره السمعه وان
تتعامل معه وفق مختلط الحادثه الى ان تتم
ادانته بالشكل الذي يحفظ كرامه وحجوك
نعم متهم من الخرطوم كان معنا المحامي عبد
الشكور حسن والكاتب الصحفي علي ابو عركي
شكرا لكما